we did a poll on the David Pakman show
YouTube channel about our audience's
opinion as to what will ultimately
happen with the confirmation of Supreme
Court nominee Brett Kavanaugh to that
Court we may ultimately know by Monday
this is not a scientific poll it's
merely a reflection of what the people
in our audience who opted to participate
believe ok I'm not presenting this as a
scientific poll the numbers are quite
clear though and we will put them up on
the screen for you and I tend to agree
with these the question was what do you
think is the most likely outcome for
Brett Cavanaugh and as of this morning
with 10,000 votes cast 49% of our
audience a plurality believes that
Cavanaugh will ultimately be confirmed
and will become the newest Supreme Court
justice second not that far behind that
Pat is that 38% of our audience believes
that Cavanaugh will not withdraw but
will ultimately fail to get the 51 or
50-plus tiebreaker from pence votes that
he needs in the Senate only 9% think
that Cavanaugh is going to withdraw and
only 5% believe that the white house
will withdraw or force Cavanaugh to
withdraw that nomination I tend to sort
of agree I had this period for a while
where I thought it doesn't matter what
happens this guy's getting confirmed
there was a brief moment where it really
seemed that the tide had turned against
Cavanaugh with multiple accusers and
that it was going to be impossible for
this guy to to continue through the
process I'm back to thinking he gets
approved yeah I don't know I mean the
tipping point would be Christine Ford's
testimony right and enough Republican
senators sympathizing with her believing
her and knowing that their constituents
are going to believe her as well and
make it so that they're not gonna push
this guy through but we don't know I
mean the Republicans will do just about
anything to get a political win and the
other thing and you mentioned this
yesterday I think we are assuming when
we say we just need a couple Republicans
to change their minds we are assuming
every Democrat votes against the sky
rarely does every Democrat vote against
a Republican president Supreme Court
pick rarely does every Republican vote
against a Democratic president Supreme
Court picks
only if we start from the assumption
that every single Democrat is going to
vote no on Cavanaugh do we even arrive
at a situation where you only need a
couple of Republicans to change their
minds could that happen
it could yeah it's the usual suspects
Murkowski there's an interesting picture
up by the way from yesterday or even
early this morning of Dianne Feinstein
seeming as though she has Murkowski kind
of cornered the implication being she
was giving her a serious talk about
Kavanagh and it could have been anything
and I don't know that it's a foregone
conclusion that Murkowski votes against
Kavanagh isn't it just crazy how you
know in response to the meats who've
moved and so many people have been taken
off television so many people have lost
their jobs and yet now it seems as
though we're going to have two Supreme
Court justices both of whom incredibly
accused of sexual assault yeah and the
President himself - it seems like for
some reason political office they don't
have to face the same consequences as
everyone else Billy Bush lost his job
because of the content of the Access
Hollywood tapes Trump was the guy in
those tapes actually saying the really
damaging stuff he was elected president
of the United States but Billy Bush lost
his job I think maybe he has a new job
now I don't know it's backwards its
backwards that's the unfortunate reality
today's program sponsored in part by
Blink is comm slash Pakman I've talked
about blinkers before it's this awesome
app that I've been using for several
months now and what it does is take the
best and most critically acclaimed
non-fiction books and condenses them
into 15-minute audiobooks that you can
listen to in one sitting you could
listen to ten books in an afternoon I
know that many in our audience want to
expand their horizons and learn more
about all sorts of different topics but
we're mostly limited by time to some
degree I know I'm not able to read all
of the books that I want simply because
I've got other stuff going on and that's
why blink is - such a great tool you can
absorb the most important information
and insights from the book in one
sitting and our audience can get a seven
day free trial by going to blink is calm
slash Pakman if you're watching on
youtube click the link in the video
description and ask
that free trial if you like blinka stand
i think you are going to like it
you can continue enjoying thousands of
condensed audiobooks for about five
bucks a month go to be li NK is t.com
slash PA k ma n